oh i went crazy shopping all for culture
though
cardi b just went on a mad shopping
spree for her two-year-old daughter
culture
and we're talking chanel and dior
oh yes honey on tuesday the 28 year old
rapper took to instagram
after dropping some serious cash on her
little girl
i went crazy shopping all for culture
though
nothing mine oh okay kate
what guy gave me a doll for a reason and
if you're curious about what's in those
boxes
don't worry she posted that too and it's
full on luxury
bags on bags on bags people
the grammy winner captioned the clip
quote this what happens when god gives
me the baby girl i
always wanted i shot more for her than i
do for myself
but cardi isn't the only one doing some
major spending on little culture
back in july for her second birthday the
toddler received her first hermes birken
bag from her famous mom
and dad rapper offset
[Music]
wow
but when eti caught up with cardi in
2019 when culture was still a baby
she insisted that it isn't all glam
all the time you want to know something
it's funny because you know you buy so
many clothes for babies
and then like the couture stuff
and the expensive name brand stuff you
put it on her
and then it's like right away she throws
up she drools or she might crap on it
and she just end up being in the in a
target outfit
you know like in a target onesie my best
pictures and videos of her is she's like
in a damn
pajamas and speaking of target
back in june cardi took culture on a toy
shopping spree
one of my favorite things about being a
mom zoe i love
going buying toys and going to the toy
section is
like i love it yeah safe to say cardi's
pretty much the sweetest girl mom
in town she's so cute i love her